what I want to do in this video is talk
a little bit about compounding
compounding interest and then have a
little bit of a discussion of a way to
quickly kind of an approximate way to
figure out how quickly something
compounds and we'll actually see how
good of an approximation this really is
so just as a review let's say I'm
running some type of a bank and I tell
you that I am offering 10 percent
interest that compounds annually
compounds compounds annually that's
usually not the case in a real bank you
would probably compound continuously but
I'm just going to keep it a simple
example compounding annually there are
other videos on compounding continuously
this makes the math a little simpler and
all that means is that let's say today
today you deposit $100 in that bank
account if we wait one year and you just
keep that in the bank account then
you'll have your hundred dollars you'll
have your hundred dollars plus 10% on
your hundred dollar deposit 10% of 100
is going to be another ten dollars so
after a year you're going to have one
hundred and ten dollars one hundred and
ten dollars you can just say I added ten
percent to the hundred and then after
two years or a year after that first
year after two years you're going to get
ten percent not just on the hundred
dollars you're going to get ten percent
on the one hundred and ten dollar so
your ten percent on 110 is you're going
to get another eleven dollars
so 10 percent 110 is $11 so you're going
to get 110 that was you can imagine your
deposit entering your second year and
then you get plus ten percent on that
not ten percent on your initial deposit
that's why we say it compounds you get
interest on the interest from previous
years so 110 plus now eleven dollars so
every year the amount of interest we're
getting if we don't redraw anything goes
up so now we have a hundred and one
hundred and twenty one dollars and I
could just keep doing that and the
general way to figure out how much you
have after let's say n years is you
multiply it so let's say
so let's say my original I'll use a
little bit of algebra here so let's say
this is my original deposit or my
principal however you want to view it
after X years so after one year you
would just multiply it to get to get to
this number right here you multiply it
by one point one one actually let me do
it this way I don't want to be too
abstract so just to get the math here so
to get to this number right here we just
multiplied that number right there is
one hundred times one plus ten percent
or you could say one point one now this
number right here is going to be this
one hundred ten times one point one
again so it's this it's the hundred
times one point one which was this
number right there and now we're going
to multiply that times one point one
again and remember where does the one
point one come from
1.1 1.1 is the same thing as one hundred
percent plus another 10 percent right
that's what we're getting we have a
hundred percent of our original deposit
plus another 10 percent so we're
multiplying by one point one here we're
doing that twice we multiply by one
point one twice so after three years how
much money do we have it's going to be
so after three years we're going to have
100 times one point one to the one point
one to the third power after n years now
we're getting a little abstract here
we're going to have a 100 times one
point one to the nth power and now you
can imagine this is not easy to
calculate and if we this was a this was
all the situation where we're dealing
with 10% if we were dealing a world with
say let's say it's seven percent so
let's say this is a different reality
here where we have seven percent
compounding annual interest then after
one year one year we would have 100
times instead of one point one it'd be
100 percent plus 7% or 1.07 after let's
skip let's go to three years after three
years I could do two in between would be
100 times 1.0 seven to the third power
one point
Oh 7 times itself 3 times after n years
would be 1.07 to the nth power so I
think you get the sense here that
although the idea is reasonably simple
to actually calculate compounding
interest is actually pretty difficult
and even more let's say I want to ask
you how long does it take how long does
it take to double your money so if you
were to just use this math right here
you'd have to say gee I would have to
double my money I would have to start
with $100 and I'm going to multiply that
times let's say whatever let's say it's
a 10% interest 1 point 1 or 1 point 10
and depending on how you're going to
view it to the X is equal to well I'm
going to double my money so it's going
to have to equal to $200 and I'm now I'm
going to have to solve for X and I'm
going to have to do some logarithms here
and you can divide both sides by 100 you
get 1 point 1 to the X is equal to 2 I
just divided both sides by 100 and then
you could take the logarithm of both
sides base 1 point 1 and you get X and
I'm showing you that this is complicated
on purpose and any of this is confusing
there's multiple videos on how to solve
these you get X is equal to log base 1.1
of 2 and most of us cannot do this in
our head so although the idea is simple
how long will it take for me to double
my money to actually solve it to get the
exact answer is not an easy thing to do
you can just keep if you have a simple
calculator you can kind of keep
incrementing the number of years until
you get a number that's close but no
straightforward way to do it and this is
with 10% if we're doing it with 9.3% it
just becomes even even more difficult so
what I'm going to do in the next video
is I'm going to explain something called
the rule of 72 which is an approximate
way to figure out how long to answer
this question how long does it take to
double your forgot the word right the
most important word how long does it
take to double your money and we'll see
how good of an approximation it is in
that next video